on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
hi I'm Rosanna Lockwood here of
uncensored tonight political praise for
the Vigilantes attacking London's car
charge cameras meanwhile the Florida
governor Ron DeSantis warns criminals
who take advantage of the storm quote
you loot we shoot so is there ever an
excuse for the public taking the Law
into their own hands
the prince against the Press again Harry
faces a backlash for his broadside
against the media's coverage of the
Afghan war have they missed the public
mode or has he
plus Eminem orders a presidential
candidate to stop rapping his songs
should politicians be allowed to use
music by musicians who hate them
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna Lockwood good evening welcome to
Pierce Morgan on scents with me Rosanna
Lockwood in the chat for the final time
before the return of the big dog on
Monday that's on the autocube big dog
when I say big dog yeah I think I would
he is back Piers Morgan in this chair
from Monday look the question we want to
ask tonight is vandalism ever okay if
it's for a cause we think is Worthy
spraying paint smashing Windows these
are the types of disruptive acts we've
got used to seeing from the likes of
Extinction rebellion and just stop oil
they say it's necessary all of this to
make the rest of us pay attention to the
looming climate catastrophe they're
critics though say they're a bunch of
loony lefties and the Damage they've
caused is Criminal outrageous and
unacceptable and it reignites debates
about how much protest action we
actually allow in our free and fair
democracy and where we draw the
legislative line so what about the Blade
Runners the name given to the group of
people currently vandalizing you less
cameras in London boroughs then doing
this in protest against the lower
Mission Zone put in place by mayor Sadiq
Khan they're being called Vigilantes and
Rebels by lots of media seemingly more
sympathetic to those political aims and
they're not seeing the same outcry to
face Justice in fact conservative MP sir
Ian Duncan Smith actually said he backs
them say and quote I am happy for them
to do it because they are facing an
imposition that no one wants and they
have been lied to about it the actions
you are seeing show how angry people are
what is being imposed on them Sadiq Khan
has gerrymandered all the information
people have had enough now all of this
begs the question do disruptive and
destructive Rebels get a pass if they
have a cause that you agree with and is
that a bit hypocritical joining me for
more on this to discuss a few topics as
well Thursday's power pack political
journalist Ava Santina talk TV
International Isabel oakshop and talk TV
presenter Richard Tice all three of you
good to have you in I mean uh Ava have
you found the characterization of the
Blade Runners do you think they're
getting an easy ride well it's just
quite interesting really isn't it
because this is Boris Johnson's policy
You Les right this was conceived by him
when he was mayor of London and then in
2020 this was pushed by Tory government
ministers they told Sadiq Khan you have
to expand you as you have to do it so
he's done it and now for some reason the
tour is probably owing to you know their
inevitable electoral failure have
decided to make a culture War out of it
and they've ramped people up and the
language that has been used around Sadiq
Khan and around you less is so
disgusting I can only understand why
people are so angry and they're now
ripping down cameras but I just I just
think it's absolutely extraordinary that
you would even conceive of comparing
them to just stop world because it's so
obvious yes just up oil are fighting for
climate change right they're peacefully
protesting they're doing things within
the bounds of the law and then you've
got these people ripping down cameras
over a silly policy is 12.50 a day or
change your car are they not you know
they've both got causes they're just at
different ends of the spectrum Richard
I'll get you head in the hands Facebook
I want to come to you first you can't
say just stop oil are just peacefully
protesting I mean incredibly disruptive
and vandalized all over the shop so I
don't think it's fair to say that
they're actually angels and the
whoever's vandalizing these cameras is
somehow but at least they've got a
different example well they've both got
causes I mean you know 12 pounds 50 a
day may not be much to you but you may
notice you may not be moving a vehicle
in and out of Central London on which
your business depends and it may only be
12 pounds 50 to an individual but people
who have businesses that involve fleets
of vehicles are finding they're gonna
have to pay an awful Richard should they
be locked up the Blade Runners look I
don't think you should welcome vandalism
I'm astonished that Ian Duncan Smith but
I think has said what he said but it
highlights just how significantly Sadiq
Khan has completely misinterpreted the
mood and I've got latest data today one
in four of all the new cameras is
believed to have been vandalized so this
is this is a level of it's sort of
low-level Anarchy and it's because
silicon's completely misjudged me but
more importantly than that he's actually
fiddled and fudged the data so that I
mean the truth is Imperial College have
confirmed that it makes no difference
whatsoever to the air pollution in terms
of the particular data and in terms of
the nitrogen dioxide that's less than
three percent it's exactly true no
because Shirley Rodriguez tried to
change the wording of the Imperial
College reports and they refused to do
it so but we're not listening to The
Experts anymore but you know look
there's been a dramatic reduction
I'm sorry you talk about
that is a lie over and you cannot do it
and for you to say it's only 12 quid 50.
nurses on night Duty it's 12 good 50 on
the way in it's 12 quid 50 on the way 25
quid nurses trying to save lives in the
NHS so point about whether or not these
people the Vandal should be treated in
the same way as Extinction Rebellion
protesters do you broadly agree with
that actually there's a massive
difference well the extinction Rebellion
have been doing is they've been damaging
private property including thousands of
pounds worth of damage to the building
that we're in for example and they don't
have to pay that's very different
producers have bought up this tweet that
you wrote about Extinction Rebellion uh
sort rather let's take a listen
every single one should be jailed for 51
weeks given a large fine and this will
stop within a fortnight but it won't
stop them but there's so many of them
Richard there really are just jail them
thousands just jail them let's build
another Detention Center
the country will celebrate there's a
fundamental difference which is they
were blocking the highway which is
prevented by law and the so the 51 weeks
is the it's the punishment sanctioned by
law in the 1980s highways code but
they're fiddling with the cameras and
that could affect the signals like that
could affect a red light signal what if
there's an accident that is caused by
one of these Vigilantes
you just made that up there is more news
to discuss today including of course
we've got new defense secretary Isabel
uh Ben Wallace after four years in the
job pretty well regarded knew he was
going to step down did it today we've
got grant shaps instead he's had four
jobs this is his fifth this year can he
do it well look gone is a really
competent Minister he's very energetic I
like Grant shouts but I don't think that
he was the right choice for a defense
secretary I wrote a book on the state of
the Armed Forces from a position of
knowing nothing about the Armed Forces
it took me a good six to nine months to
get a basic grip on how defense works
this is not something that you can just
dip into and suddenly know what you're
talking about in reality this is a very
dangerous time geopolitically we've got
a war going on in Europe and the
conservatives probably have no more than
a year absolute maximum in power so it
seems to me extraordinary to have
appointed somebody who knows nothing
about defense has no background or
relevant skill whatsoever for the
defense job when Rishi sunak had his
pick of people who actually do know what
they're talking about who would that
have been in your mind well I don't want
to suggest particular people but there
are plenty of people with background in
the armed forces who could have
appointed for example James hepey who
has the relevant experience Ava anything
to swing for the defensive Grant straps
in your eyes oh well I think it's a
tough one isn't it you know he's had
five jobs in the last last year so I
guess he's qualified and I don't know
moving shape-shifting or something like
that but you know he also did have that
half day in October last year when he
was chairing the appg on Ukraine and he
actually visited Ukraine didn't he
probably a little bit more than the rest
of them but you know poor Grant getting
a bad looking at the moment but it is it
is the majority view at the moment I'm
afraid that he's just about a cabinet
reshuffle away uh Richard Mitch
McConnell freezing again this is in the
U.S of course Republican Senate minority
leader Mitch McConnell appearing to
freeze during a press conference
what running for real
re-elect 2026.
oh sure
did you hear the question Senator
running for re-election in 2026
all right I'm sorry you all we're gonna
need a minute
I mean in broadcasting dead air is a
crime where you just allow seconds to
pass that's painful to listen to
obviously it's not broadcasting he's 81
years old he was asked whether he would
run for re-election and he just paused I
mean it's the second time I think in
about six or eight weeks that this has
happened to him you you feel for him
from a personal level from a health
point of view
it is extraordinary in American politics
how people seem to go on and on and on
to the point where that happens we see
some you know pretty uh bad things
happen with Joe Biden you know has he or
hasn't he got dementia it's so different
to how things occur politically here I
mean once you're sort of a north of 65
let alone 70 here the serious question
my heart let alone in your 80s and sadly
we're now seeing the consequences I
don't think you could set an age limit
but there has to be a you don't a health
and competence level
Pilots can't fly Beyond 60 operating
heavy machinery that you know has the
lives of many in their hands I mean
surely the government classes many lives
yeah I mean also like you can't you have
to get a new driving license every year
after 70. you know I mean if you can't
drive without someone checking that
you're okay to do it the black man
clearly can't drive I would not want him
behind the wheel of a car he shouldn't
be in charge of legislation and to me it
just sort of reads a toxic masculinity
because what I don't understand is why
is this man holding this position not
giving it to someone younger why isn't
he moving out the way
Stand Down couldn't he he doesn't look
toxicity to me
you know look I think it was horrible to
watch I don't like to watch I just think
you wonder what these people's families
are saying you know why aren't the
families saying look you're clearly not
in any position to be in this job it
strikes me as a little bit negligent on
the part of those who love him and I
will say on behalf of the masculinity
around us Nancy Pelosi held onto her
position on it still holds for a long
long time and she's certainly no spring
chicken either let's take a look though
at something else a little lighter that
we wanted to give you a look at
a beach towel that apparently looks like
Elvis take a look can you see Elvis in
this a couple have been All Shook Up
This is in their holiday in Greece then
it is an uncanny resemblance the king of
rock and roll on the gray beach towel
can you see it Myra hindley
I can't see that at all no okay now I
can just about see it that's yeah that's
that's lost on me when they said Elvis
on the beach Tower I thought you meant
an actual like body double yeah
I think it's a stretch you know we call
this silly season in news uh in August
where people are just scrabbling around
pieces of toast and some toast stories
pies yeah clouds Jesus and the bacon
we've seen it all
speaking of which do get your thinking
hats on because we're going to get you
back in about half an hour's time to ask
you what your favorite news stories of
the summer were to wrap up this while we
go back to school with Piers Morgan on
Monday we look forward to see you back
here in the studio shortly well
uncensored next tonight is the Duke of
Sussex picks yet another fight with the
tabloids in his latest Netflix
documentary we'll debate who the public
are backing in the ongoing Battle of the
prince versus The Press
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Minister President Trump Mr President
first lady Stormy Daniels John Peterson
welcome to all these people protesting
just don't get it any of them don't it's
not slightly patronizing
when you're going through the treatments
you have some tears God I'm such a softy
I'm not a performing monkey come on
Brian and it's something that really
hurt me because they doubt of my words
a woman is me a woman is somebody whose
breasts hang down to her stomach I
thought the marginalized we're supposed
to have the voice I've been a terrible
liar
you're being a Karen pass Morgan
kiss condoms the kiss caskets will get
you coming and we'll get you going I
think it's only room for one king man
now I'm saying
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now the
latest battle in the seemingly
never-ending war between Prince Harry
and the Press is centered around this
moment at the moment from his new
Netflix documentary heart of Invictus
three young British soldiers
all wrapped in plastic and their bodies
in pieces
I saw what only people had talked about
that was the real trigger for I'm now
seeing the real cost of War
stepping foot off the plane
I was angry that this has happened to
these guys I was angry that the media
weren't covering it
in response to that accusation that the
media weren't covering at the time the
sun publish this front page today
stating quote we did care Harry and we
still do citing its extensive support
for the forces over the years now the
question of course is who the public
backs in this latest Skirmish between
The Prince and the press or are we all
just fed up with the fighting well to
debate this I'm joined by the author and
historian Tessa Dunlop the former Royal
and former Defense editor at the sun
Duncan larkham plus the former head of
Royal protection dye Davis three of you
thank you for joining me Tess I'll come
to you first because
is there any part of you that can
understand why the press the British
media have got so up and arms about that
one sentence in this Netflix documentary
about the Press not caring I mean the
Press need clicks they need oxygen
um it's so obvious why they've gone for
that one line I can understand why
they've sort of there's a lot of
Umbridge going on because it's true
actually for over 100 years our tabloid
press have been very good at campaigning
particularly for British soldiers and
the help for Heroes campaign that muscle
like that tabloid muscle I think
shouldn't be underestimated but at the
same time Harry's reality in that moment
and if you look back because I did check
back uh to 2015 the time you've taken
off it's an Angry Young chap at the time
because his story had been leaked in in
the American Press not fair enough the
British press and so he is brought back
to Britain and all the headlines in that
moment around that time were about Harry
not about those critically injured
soldiers in the same airplane so there
are two truths in this story let's bring
in Duncan on that responding to Tessa's
point then that their focus at the time
really was on Harry and not on the
soldiers
yes it was but in that plane was a guy
called Ben McBean who was a double
amputee that's one of the wounded
soldiers Harry was talking about and he
worked with the son for years after that
um we paid him a lot of got involved
with him and we we helped
um draw attention to wounded soldiers so
Harry's just
uh it's just once again a picture and
bassing it on lies frankly I don't go on
Tessa I think well I just think lies to
Barrel accusation is is unhelpful I
think we can step back and say that was
one line Duncan in a five-part series
which I think generally has seen people
come in behind it the consensus is this
is an impressive series indeed it's an
important series at the moment let's
bring a die sorry a Duncan I will come
back to you but die former head of Royal
protection uh there's no sort of big
surprise to anyone but Harry doesn't
like the media he's been waging legal
complaints against them and you know
Battle of his own against them so does
this come as any surprise to you
no it doesn't come as any surprise uh
surprisingly I agree with a great deal
that Tessa dunno has said sometimes I
don't always agree but on this occasion
I I do however there is the truth and
then there's Harry truth and I think
that's been demonstrated many many times
now uh over the last few years he has
his truth and I'm no doubt he believes
it but I think with great respect he's
been to the same school of advice as his
Uncle Andrew in other words not very
good I I think we should concentrate
more on these injured people he's
getting all the publicity we should
really be concentrating on these
amputees and these poor men and women
who have suffered they're the key things
and I think Harry with great respect you
should stand to one side and emphasize
more the fact that you are helping them
but so are many many others including
the Press die have you watched the heart
and vixors I know it's five parts and
you've probably got a busy life but have
you tuned into it at all
no In fairness I haven't I've just heard
all day and I've been commenting like
you probably all day I've just done a
six and a half hour Journey from North
Wales down to here to speak to you guys
so no I haven't had a chance I will out
of professional curiosity and the
ability to speak honestly and sincerely
but uh with great respect let's
concentrate on those men and women who
have been injured they suffered far more
than Harry ever has to die with great
respect the series imbalance is 90
the injured veterans of war and about 10
the Duke of Sussex with a flash in the
pan couple of moments including the
duchess I actually think what's
impressive about the series is the
balance it's Harry light just enough of
the magic Royal fairy dust and where the
the imbalance if you like has come in is
the Press coverage off the back of the
series Duncan I want to bring you uh
back in on this because one of the
points of the sun has she raised which
they're calling uh one of Harry's lies
on this is that at the Milly's award
ceremony in 2011 Harry attended gave a
keynote speech and thanks all of those
involved in laying on the marvelous
evening this is a campaign backing help
for Heroes which the sun helped launch
uh is that the main point of contention
here
in organizing the entire event
for Harry to say that the plight of
British soldiers wounded in Afghanistan
was ignored by the Press I'm sorry it's
it's not true and when what what do we
do we have to call out a prince who is
telling lie after lie after lie
well Tessa what does that uh empowers
that impact public sympathies towards
Harry
I I totally understand that Duncan as a
former tabloid editor feels passionate
about the good that tabloids do because
often we talk about the bad they do
including Harry in that narrative
incidentally however to accuse him of
telling lie after lie is over egging the
pudding yes he said in that moment he
felt the attention was on him why wasn't
it on the maimed victims of war but
actually his whole series is on the pity
of war and I think it's beautifully
constructed and it's not full of Harry
lies so look let's not pile on the
inaccuracies and double down on them
let's stand back and say that was one
line one emotive line from Harry but
otherwise I think the series at this
time when there's a little bit of a
wobble going on behind the Ukraine
campaign it's a force for the good let's
Let One Lie go that doesn't matter the
fact is uses his platform days to
distort and to give false account of
what is the reality and we're getting
the public again
and tells lies
yes it's not acceptable it's fake news
Duncan your um line is slightly break
out so I don't mean to break into you
totally they're hoping re-established I
want to go to die in the meantime and
just ask that idea of the public
sympathy side of this are they seeing
more about the Invictus games and the
soldiers this is rehabilitating Harry's
image this documentary or is it a PR
backfire
well I don't know is the honest truth
because I haven't seen it so I I will as
it were stand judgment but reading some
of the comments I have on various uh
social media about six thousand to one
really don't support him which is sad
um in respect to what uh tested said
perhaps if he put two or three percent
in about himself other than the 10 but I
do say he's a grown man now he's 40. yes
he's experienced things but so have so
many and to keep harping on about it
with great respect I don't think he does
himself Justice and indeed I agree with
Duncan that some of the things he has
said uh even about his brother on this
occasion as I understand it uh isn't
true he was supported and arguably he's
had more support than most people you
think about a Squatty that were brought
up in a counselor estate and had two
legs blown off and a thing how much
support other than from the help the
heroes and indeed the military tree and
I think it's decrying it I I know a lot
of Military Officers and men and and
they're absolutely horrified so they
tell me uh in the short period we've had
about what he's coming out with this is
I've often heard Harry tell his story
and it's never elicited a tear I've
never cried for Harry I was flying back
yesterday from Romania and I watched two
episodes back to back and the man said
are you all right love tears pouring
down my cheeks because the stories in
that heart of Invicta series are so
moving nothing to do with Prince Harry
so I would beseech both you and Duncan
to please watch it first and comment
second and I think we found a
replacement for Stacey Dooley or perhaps
a partner I mean he's quite brilliant
he's very congenial he's very warm this
is Harriet's best even the Times
newspaper said that I really beseech you
to watch it Duncan die that's your
viewing for this evening sorted a
causing to test it done
sorry Duncan your line isn't as clear as
he's watched it twice
to watch a five-part series twice
I always respect what you say and I
certainly will take up the offer uh once
I've had a cup of tea you go put the
kettle on die
Duncan die and Tessa thank you very much
I'm centered next tonight after
Republican presidential candidate Vivek
ramaswamy attempts to wrap one of
Eminem's biggest hits the rapper issues
a cease and desist letter to stop him
should politicians be allowed to use
music by musicians who hate them
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
Cube I think there's only one for one
king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean
you believe you can win this war but
it's making me cry again I'm trying to
force you out yes I feel betrayed keep
it award-winning
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a board she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they've bent the rules or lied on the
visa application form and therefore got
it there needs to be an intervention
around abortion laws Parliament is
Sovereign Parliament can determine these
things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
let it roll
[Music]
producing oil the knock-on effect is far
larger than just CO2 I nearly have
empathy when I'm speaking to them I know
you're probably going to whoop me after
church
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
been telling materials you don't drink
never taken drunk you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to the show now one of the
most unexpected rap battles in history
is underway on the left perhaps in more
ways than one that's Eminem on the right
you get the idea that's high-flying
presidential hopeful Vivek ramaswamy
this unlikeliest of spats began when
Vivek went viral for wrapping to
Eminem's Lose Yourself at the Iowa State
Fair
now Eminem's lawyers after that issued
an immediate cease and desist letter
Banning Rama Swami from ever doing it
again at least in public so it was
Eminem right to protect Integrity of his
work in this Urban genre from
appropriation by a wealthy politician or
has he lost himself to debate all of it
I'm joined by Los Angeles America's
number one Eminem impersonator on
YouTube Vincent Marcus Maga rapper
Forgiato blow he is in Florida for us
and outkick host Tommy Lara in front of
the show joining us from Nashville as
ever
um I will come to you first Forgiato uh
is the performance worth it was Vivek
doing any good
I get my 8 out of 10.
um I think Eminem needs to go back to
reality though The Real Slim Shady needs
to stand up you know he made his whole
career on bashing White America picking
on people to get on he is the face of
hate speech when hate speech even
started I don't see any problem with egg
doing the song I mean does he have a
problem with the man of color playing
his music no one Detroit's ever played
his music he seems like he thinks his
music is for drug dealers and drug users
a white America bought his music so
there shouldn't be an issue it's freedom
of speech I feel Vincent you're the
number one Eminem impersonator what did
you make in a performance
uh I thought it was great uh nine out of
ten because he really had the you know
step back too he had the like the Eminem
perfect perfect inflection on there so
uh I really really nice job there
um yeah I think he did great so why did
Eminem not like it then
I think that's obviously politically
motivated I think because he was so
anti-trump locally very vocally so much
in fact the Secret Service came to him
and questioned him about his lyrics and
the validity of them and so I think he
just wants to stay out of politics and
he's like uh maybe not you know I'm out
I think he I think he learned his lesson
on that for a little bit well let's
remind ourselves of the number of
musicians that have banned Donald Trump
a certain former president from playing
their music at his events Adele
Aerosmith The Beatles Bruce Springsteen
Eddie Grant Elton John I mean I go
Pavarotti Nickelback Pharrell Williams
Phil Collins prince Queen REM I mean it
goes on and on and on Tommy what's all
this about
oh I think it's obviously politically
motivated and I'm sure Eminem Slim Shady
doesn't want a republican candidate
singing to his song but the real winner
here is actually Vivek because although
he might have gotten that cease and
desist letter it really doesn't matter
because we're talking about it and
that's what Vivek wants he wants to
create some kind of a controversy he
wants to get earned media air time and
this story has continued to progress so
by Eminem's company Slim Shady by them
sending the cease and desist letter
they've just really helped Vivek out get
him more air time get more pressed about
the issue and it's also cemented his
Underdog status right which people love
yeah I mean you've got a point Tommy
we're talking about it right now here on
a show from the UK it's got our
attention that much Forgiato coming to
you I mean Rama Swami he's had a life of
some privilege compared to Eminem he
went to Yale and Harvard Forbes says
he's worth 950 million dollars is it
cultural appropriation
I don't think it is because with Eminem
be where he was at if he didn't have G
Unit or in 50 Cent walking him in and Dr
Dre getting them where he was going I
mean Eminem yeah he probably had to
struggle just like everybody here it
wasn't easy for you to get your job but
you know I think vivec's doing a good
job like we're saying he's getting his
name out there obviously I'm voting
Trump but I like that that I think he's
doing a good job on the campaign trails
and you know he did say he'll pardon
Trump so I like that okay Vincent uh in
terms of just politicians trying to seem
cool using rap music to try and get
attention like Tommy was saying is it at
all worth it do you think it helps them
in the polls
I think so I mean if I I really enjoyed
the performance and I think that it
definitely did help or it will because
again like the time you said we're
talking about it so
again I think it uh I think it's a nice
tool to for politicians to use to sort
of gain some traction
um but yeah I think uh I I don't say
again I don't see anything wrong with
what he did but again if you get a
season just List season desist later
from Eminem
that's pretty gangster that's cool like
that's cool in itself so like Eminem the
biggest gangster of all time was just
like you know what
maybe you want to pull back a little bit
but maybe maybe pull back so that's just
that's cool in itself Vincent have you
ever met Eminem has you ever sent you a
cease to desist letter no if I got one
from him I would say oh my gosh I exist
I would love that but no uh no he has
not reached out I have not met him yet I
would love to
um but no not yet okay all right well
maybe he'll watch this and maybe he'll
get in touch with you and tell you what
he makes of your impersonations look
Tommy
politicians uh Connor trying to seem
cool let's look at this latest clip
we've got of a certain Ted Cruz
they're trying to go after and regulate
ceiling fans I got to tell you it's hot
in Texas we don't want to get rid of our
ceiling fans and now these idiots have
come out and said drink two beers a week
that's their guideline well I got to
tell you if they want us to drink two
beers a week frankly they can kiss my
ass
no okay
um
left the news anchor there pretty pretty
speechless Tommy that is Ted Cruz
getting some chaps some cowboys behind
into a crack open a brewski at the same
time and to prove what a down to earth
guy he is does this kind of stick work
I think it actually is pretty authentic
to Ted Cruz to speak that way I mean
he's a Texan so I think that it
resonates and as long as he's not
drinking Bud Light I think that the
Republican party is going to be okay
with it as we know with the Bud Light
controversy so that's a sore spot for
conservatives being that the Bud Light
boycott is still ongoing but I'll say
this it really depends on your audience
right so he's a Texan that's the way
Texans talk the vague he's a young guy
rapping although when when they try to
play up to this hip cool attitude around
an audience of like Iowa State Fair
goers I'm not sure that it really
resonates with that audience but I think
it's all about just being authentic you
know if we've got Chris Christie up
there rapping 50 Cent I'm not sure that
that's going to do well for him so it
depends on the time the place and the
person if you've got a natural swag you
can do it let's not forget that Donald
Trump over the years has been in dozens
of rap songs so he's actually the OG of
this before they hated him they love to
rap about him well how about Trump
rapping this latest clip that has
appeared on line an AI developed Trump
rap track that's topping the charts
got homies doing life in jail they live
in it now these days acting silly my mud
shot is where the Billy sells the
merchant made a militia
baby
butcher then my rollers called me racist
but these rappers riding with me they're
my soldiers
poor gianto is that is that any good in
your mind
yeah I think it was great it's great for
the culture any song that shouts out
Danny Johnson I love it
um I was outside the jailhouse and a lot
of people weren't really showing the
support you know Donald Trump's getting
from the brown and black community they
were out there so I think it was really
cool you know there's a lot of people
like myself out here doing a lot of
things so shout out high res I'm glad
you got that spot I hope he gets that
number one spot for Donald Trump and
just uh quickly though I mean there's a
lot of lyrics in there that obviously
Trump hasn't said himself but AI has
created about shooting people I mean
it's that kind of help his campaign
I didn't hear anything in there about
shooting anybody so I didn't hear that
but I think it just you know sometimes
people just gotta laugh and have fun
right everything's so serious people
weren't worried about Eminem when he was
talking about robbing killing and
shooting every gay person in America now
they're supporting him so you know I
just think that was great
I like the song Eminem not running for
president though obviously Trump didn't
create that song himself it's AI
generated maybe I misheard the shooting
thing I'll take it back and listen again
but one thing we do want to listen to
again and this is with Vincent in mind
very carefully let's once again listen
to Vivek Rama Swami rapping Eminem
now Vincent America's Got Talent that's
what you were involved in you're
America's number one Eminem impersonator
how should he have done that better give
us a go
um I very close to it but you got to hit
that ah you gotta hit that because it
starts off with the whisper right but if
it starts to get mad it goes back to
slam stage two but then we start to get
really pissed off it starts to scream is
lose yourself in the music the moment
you want it you better never let it go
you only get one shot do not miss your
chance to blow this opportunity comes
once in a lifetime you better though
that's that's how I would very good very
very good you've got
you've got us convinced too gentleman
fortiato Vincent thanks very much Tommy
do stick around we're going to keep you
on for the end of the show talk a few
more things newsy from the summer it's
been great talking to you all
uncensored next tonight from a stricken
submersible to a presidential mug shot
with an unwanted kiss in between the
summer of 23 has not been a quiet one
but what we'll Define it we'll find out
next
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
shots promoted to defense secretary
should teenagers be forced into National
service and Rogue police officers can
now be sacked on this spot that's all at
nine o'clock
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored on Monday the
Lord of this manner Piers Morgan is
going to be back in charge after his
summer break refreshed restored recharge
he's had a good time he's also done a
bit of work this week so given it's my
last show here in prepay isn't the last
one before the new term begins we
thought it'd be interesting to look back
at some of the stories that have defined
at summer 2023 around the world here to
present their own picks political
journalist Ava Santina talk to the
international editor Isabel oakshot and
talk TV presenter Richard Tice and
Nashville outkick host Tommy Lauren
still with us as well all four of you
thanks for bearing with us on this one
it is the end of August we thought it
was worthy Richards start by telling us
what you think the most important or the
best story of the summer was the most
extraordinary story for me has been this
barge the Bibi Stockholm it's almost
there with like we feel as though we've
stayed on it because it's been this sort
of dead cat that the government threw
out there is the solution to the hotel
crisis for the uh for the Asylum Seekers
and it's been just catastrophe after
catastrophe after catastrophe you know
was it uh was it sort of certified in
terms of its fire safety yes or no big
questions over that uh then actually the
some of the first migrants actually
arrived on board and then someone says
oh have we checked the water does it
work or is it does it tested or not oh
no it's not so within three or four days
they're taken off and you think well
this has just gone from from bad to
worse and now the fire brigade Union
once again is saying actually uh that
it's uh it's not going to be safe never
will be safer the number that they
wanted you sort of think that basically
uh this has just been a distraction
it'll never be occupied it's a bit like
the Rwanda scheme it'll never happen
it's sort of red herring it's so fast
isn't it you know and you forgot the bit
about one of the Asylum Seekers or their
lawyers claiming that they're afraid of
water which is slightly unfortunate in
terms of their choice of coming to
Britain you know a country that is
unfortunately for them an island and is
constantly deluged by rain you know you
just couldn't make this stuff up it's
just been lurching from one ridiculous
situation to another loads of loads of
money wasted it's so classically British
the Bibi Stockholm barge that's
Richard's Choice let's go to Tommy now
and ask you Tommy what was your story of
the summer
well I don't know if it hits the same
over in the UK but I'll tell you here in
the United States of America I think the
biggest story of the summer revolves
around kind of what I talked about in
the last segment and that is the
absolute tanking the funeral of the
iconic American brand Bud Light after
that disastrous partnership with the
Trans Tick-Tock influencer Dylan
Mulvaney so this is a big deal in the
United States not just because of an
iconic American brand really suffering
huge losses but also because this is one
of the first times that conservatives in
the USA have led a boycott that's had
sticking power and it's not just Bud
Light Target sales dropping we've had
the explosion of popularity of songs
like try that in a small town by Jason
Aldean and then Richmond north of
Richmond by Oliver Anthony music so we
are actually taking a stand here we are
canceling cancel culture but we're also
taking a stand for some of our ideas our
rights our ideologies our convictions it
really hasn't been done a lot on the
conservative side but boy we're just
getting started over here well tell me
I've seen some conservative commentator
States I'd actually say ask their fellow
peers and conservative Community to stop
talking about Dylan Mulvaney so much
because you're just giving them air time
what do you make of that
well Dylan Mulvaney is going to get
airtime regardless I mean just got a
streamy award earlier this week for
breakout content creator Dill Mulvaney's
not going anywhere but I'll tell you
this there are going to be students
studying the Bud Light marketing
disaster for generations to come I'll
tell you that one this is a lesson in
marketing or in this case how not to
Market your brand to American consumers
so hopefully lesson learned Ava I can
see you having some reactions here in
the studio Tommy said it may be to
American for a British audience do you
agree well no I mean it hit over here
didn't it it was a huge story here but I
mean I think also the cultural
significance of Bud Light I mean
particularly the sort of people who were
out now it was Kid Rock who was
particularly furious with it I think he
actually shot her a can of it off the
side of his property I mean perhaps that
you know the South wasn't ready for
um something is well I mean look I I
think in Britain as well I think we
quite enjoy
um
what do you even say to this I just
don't even think it's a problem and I
just think the whole blow up of it is
just a bit of the culture war and quite
sad actually and it's kind of but it's
actually it's it's Consumer Power I'll
never buy Bud Light again
it's a good drink I like Bud Light but I
will consciously not buy it again
just as I won't go to Costa anymore and
so you know that go work go broke it's
very clear and they're going broke well
I don't know I mean I wouldn't be caught
dead with a Bud Light but that's because
I like an actual beer but you know there
you go
and coming in with the swipes look
Isabel let's give you your chance to
tell us your story this summer so this
is actually a much more serious and sad
one which is the Titanic uh submarine
story I just think that this tale
journalistically and on a human interest
level was utterly gripping you know the
whole world was watching as to the fate
of these poor people who went down there
and of course literally they weren't
poor the reason they were in that sub in
the first place is because they were
able to afford an incredibly expensive
tickets to go down in this glorified tin
can and that was part of the debate
wasn't it people all thought well if I
had that money if I had 250 000 which I
think was the price per ticket would I
have spent it in that way everybody
could in some way relate to whether you
would or wouldn't actually put yourself
in that position and the whole kind of
hour by hour is the oxygen running out
what is the way out for them the rescue
attempts it was just it was just awful
and one of those stories where every
morning you'd wake up and I think even
some of us journalists wake up in the
middle of the night might have checked
our phones to see if there was any
update and so sad that it had such an
awful ending I think you've summed it up
well it was a conflicting story and
that's why it pulled on so many
heartstrings I've anchored a two-hour
special we did here on talktv that
evening about it and spoke to lots of
friends of Survivor you know of some of
the men rather victims that went down uh
you know and they were talking heartfelt
you know heart-rending stories about the
people that they were missing you know
and that they were explorers and
everything else
adventure and you had the technical
information yeah what's the man who was
running the organization Ocean Gate had
led them into and for many when you
actually drilled into it it was an
accident waiting to happen it was a
tragedy that people had forecast so
there's there's a there's a lot of
information that came out afterwards and
I suspect more will come out with the
inquiry is in due course and you'll
surely be made into a film yeah a bit
like the time boy the boy's stuck in the
Thai cave you know the hour-by-hour
Moment by moment brilliant drama but
just a horrible tragic ending we even
heard that night of the sort of coverage
of it from James Cameron himself who of
course director Titanic and was sort of
stunned by what was unfolding Tommy was
the Titan submersible story such a big
deal in the US as it was here
oh it absolutely was I think it gripped
the entire world and a few stories have
the ability to do that and have that
kind of reach obviously a horrible
tragedy and something that we all felt
and I think it's a moment we can all
come together as well there's been so
many things dividing us all over the
world and so when we can come together
and we can pray for people and we can
think of people and we can cover a story
and discuss a story I think that's the
silver lying all of it is it reminds us
that we all have the same heart at the
end of the day so certainly a story of
the summer Ava coming to you now what is
your story this summer it was Brian
Johnson this millionaire who wants to
look like his son and so he's getting up
at five o'clock in the morning he's
eating his last meal by 11 A.M he's
stuffing 54 pills into himself during
that time he's sleeping for actually not
very long but he's injecting himself
with all sorts and apparently he looks
he looks younger but to me he looks
about his age which is around 45 I mean
I think that looks quality of life this
is what I find so weird he's spending so
much time trying to prolong his life
where's the fun in his actual life well
yeah totally and you've got to I mean I
wonder how the sun feels I mean would
you like it if your your mother I think
Freud would have a lot to say about this
about the motivations behind why he's
doing this competing with his son as
well but I mean Richard if you give me
the opportunity to make yourself 20
years younger in appearance
I I thought it sounded a miserable
existence everything was so regimented I
mean you know you've had to book a slot
if you want to have sex or anything the
whole thing is completely ridiculous
what's what's life's worth for enjoying
it a bit of you know spontaneous
activity
one would think so look Tommy uh did you
follow this story and would you be
tempted to make yourself yeah I mean
look you look gorgeous anyway
listen I'm 31 years old so if you took
20 years off of me I don't think I could
be on this program right now because he
was still in elementary school but Hey
listen I think another story of the
summer is the wide use of ozempic and
semi-glutide in Hollywood and around the
world I mean that's kind of similar to
this story but that really blew up over
the summer and I don't think it's going
anywhere anytime soon yeah you're right
there Tommy and you know what Piers
Morgan was also talking about zenpick
when he was over in La a few weeks ago
saying that he's not following the
Olympic diet tweeted a picture of a big
steak in front of him but he said
everyone it seems to be on it over there
now my favorite story of the summer I
know you're gonna know this one it was
great it gripped all of us this is the
bear that was not a human in a bear suit
in the Hangzhou zoo in China there's
some bear that stood up waving we've
sensitive to the lower half of the bear
I do enjoy that from the from behind he
does look up like a bit of a I think
it's a female bear actually but does
look like a human in a bear suit it got
a lot of people talking was it really a
bear was it a human and from various
angles I could have been convinced on
either side but apparently really is a
sun bear I mean Isabel were you
convinced initially when I first glance
saw I thought that's ridiculous that's
definitely a person in a bear suit but
then I did a bit of research on what
these bears look like and that is what
they look like so yeah it was a bear Ava
they say that the uh attendance at these
zoos has gone up through the roof now
whoever wants to go see a sun bear would
you go I'm fascinated to know what was
blurred you know what was taken off of
the screen there so maybe I will go and
have a look investigate myself
but fantastic marketing if that's the
truth if yeah if the numbers went up
brilliant let's take another look at it
again would this convince you to give
away to Hangzhou and China you don't
have to go to Hangzhou in fact you can
go to other zoos as well lots of them
piled in on this I mean it's a great
looking bear
as well but the Chinese Zoo did deny it
was strange I do sometimes wonder
whether there is a little bit of kind of
latent racism here with people assuming
that the Chinese are just trying to hide
something from all of us and that they
really put a human in a bear suit and
they had to really prove here that this
is what sun bears do actually look like
thanks all four of you for joining us
for that silly end of summer peace
before peers returns to the show on
Monday don't miss that thank you so much
to my panel Tommy Ava Isabelle and
Richard that's it from me on uncensored
it has been a pleasure sitting in Fort
Pierce he's gonna be back on Monday with
those big guests big views big
interviews whatever you're up to make
sure it's uncensored and do vote from
the ntas as well good night
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war making me cry again they're trying
to force you out yes I feel betrayed
keep it award-winning
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a board she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
let it roll
yeah
[Music]